NOW MIKKO.
DRIVING TOGLASS.
GIRARD.
LANDESKOG ON THE ICE FOR HIS
FIRST SHORES.
NATHAN IM IN PRACTICE, AS
DEVON TOEWS ACTIVATES.MACKINNON.
>> MOSE, RIGHT NOW FORKINNON.
SCORE!
A SHORTHANDED
HARD AND HE GETS HIS FIRST GOAL
WITH THE COLORADODO A REVERSE H.
HEARINGS MAKAR.
HE SCORES!
NOW YOU SEE KUEMPPZONE. GET AN
SCORED
AGAINST THE BLACKHAWKS
JOSI. FOR
MANSON.
SWEEPS IT OFF FOR TOPOST, SCORE.
THEY WERE PUTTING THE PUCK ON  .
SAVED.ONE, STURM GOT HIS STICK
KUHNEN.
THE AVS
THAT WAS A ROCKET.
>> PETER: MOSELY SAY IT AGAIN.
YOU AND I HAVE UP.
SHOOTS AND SCORES.
BLOCKER.
THAT IS REALLY A NICE GOAL.
SITUATION LIKE THIS. DIFFERENT
COMPLEXBACK.
>> MARC: I'M SURE YOU WERE
A BIG BODY AT